il est quand même pour ces acteurs
économique difficile de comprendre qu'
on puisse laisser les clients fréquenter
les par exemple les grandes surfaces et
puis dans leurs commerces de plus petite
taille ou en général il n'y a pas je
dirais en même temps surabondance de
clients leur dire vous garder le rideau
fermé parce que derrière c'est c'est une
deuxième vague je dirais de fermeture
vous baisser de rideau pendant que
d'autres peuvent ouvrir et pourtant ces
commerçants qui souhaitent pouvoir
exercer leur activité
le fonds est savent qu'ils auront déjà
un chiffre d'affaires moins important
qu'à man men été sacrifié ses commerces
de proximité ces petits commerces pour
vous lors de cette deuxième vague mais
en tous les cas à défaut d'être
sacrifiée mais le ya risque d'abord
qu'un certain nombre et du mal à s'en
relever
[Musique]